hello again ty yet again congratulations
oh thank you i love this one so much oh
cool so it's been a good while since in
a valley of violence but i know you've
kept pretty busy on the tv side of
things but was there any particular
reason that now felt like the right time
to switch back to features with x it'd
been a while since i made a horror movie
i had i needed a break
and i had this sort of idea kicking
around for a little while and you know
doing tv is a different job i like it
just as much but it is they are two
different things um and i was really
enjoying myself and then i started to
feel like i had done i did a lot in a
row like i did like 17 episodes in a row
like i was like one after another which
was great
but i felt very sharp because i had
spent a lot of reps on set and i felt
like if there was ever a time i should
probably do it while i'm like this sharp
from going one show to another
and i wanted to make something that was
very like craft driven and craft focus
and and like had a sort of reverence for
cinema as part of it so i
that's the timing just lined up i was
like if i'm ever going to do it i'm as
sharp as i'm ever going to be right now
this idea has been kicking around it's
not going anywhere 824 is crazy enough
to do it we should just do it
tails from the loop was underrated not
enough people watching
that's the best show i've ever done i
love that show breaks my heart a little
bit uh
why this story now for you as a feature
director was there anything that was
there anything that you were able to
achieve on x that you know specifically
came from the fact that you did you know
house of the devil innkeepers etc before
yeah i mean not not one thing i mean
it's kind of all of it and then the tv
goes into that as well just the just the
experience of having made more you just
get better just like anything else um
but for me i just felt like i felt like
my own personal experience was that
horror movies had gotten a little soft i
never wanted to make a slasher movie
i kind of felt like well i never wanted
to but people aren't really making that
many slasher movies and horror movies
feel kind of soft maybe now's the time
i had this idea that i wanted to make
something that was i have a great deal
of reverence for cinema as an art form
and it's a crazy thing that people go do
and i feel like less and less people
grasp that than they used to because
we're so bombarded with content all the
time so i wanted to make a movie where
the characters in the movie were making
a movie to kind of invite you in to kind
of be charmed by what it takes to make a
movie um and if i could do that then i
could also give the audience kind of a
crash course in what i'm doing in the
movie and so if i could make something
that really kind of like put the craft
of filmmaking
into the story in a way that was
charming and that would hopefully make
people like think movies are cool that
seemed worthwhile to do to me because i
sometimes feel i'm missing that and um
it also just seemed like a challenge and
it seemed like a way to
challenge myself to hopefully elevate
some craft to have the composer do that
to have the costume designer do that and
to have the cinematographers do that and
to have like the actors do it hence the
mia situation instead of like and
special effects makeup do that it was
like i just want to see what would
happen if we really just took a very low
brow sub genre and tried to do something
like with a high level of craft you
legit look like you could be in that
cabin right now
i know that's funny that someone had an
interview with me and they were like the
creepy cabin and i was like
like not my head they were like the
creepy cabin in the movie and i was like
i thought it was okay i thought i was
kind of cozy
a little bit uh why particularly the uh
1970s for this movie what was it about
you know that decade versus others that
you think just best serve these
particular themes that you were
exploring
uh i think the two biggest reasons are
like in the story and the narrative of
the movie like the mid 70s is when vhs
started to really become a viable option
uh it obviously boomed in the 80s but if
you were someone who was like an
outsider of the film business and saw an
opportunity to get in like say wayne
does entrepreneurial speaking
it was like the late 70s was the time if
you were getting early on vhs and to get
in early on making independent movies no
matter the type that would have been the
time to do that and make some money so
it made sense then and then because the
movie was like
going to be craft driven um and
filmmaking driven i would say that like
the 1970s
is probably as like lauded at the time
in american cinema as there is and it's
a time where
uh
successful movies were also a little
experimental and were very sort of like
oftentimes filmmaker driven and like uh
cinema driven like
it just is the decade of that so it made
sense to me just for fun did you ever
think how the story might play out if it
happened today
and it was not interesting it was like
it was people on webcams
i mean you're probably not if you were
trying to make legit if you were to
logically take it to a place of what if
it was made today it would not be
you wouldn't necessarily go to that
place you wouldn't necessarily shoot it
the way you did it it wouldn't be as
difficult for those characters they
wouldn't need to be feeling it we would
take a lot of the sort of like love of
cinema out of it and it would become
very much like get on this webcam and
show something and we're going to make
some money and that in many ways was
like that was antithetical to what the
movie was like there was a movie when i
wrote this movie that people had in
their head that they were terrified i
could be making and then the movie that
it actually is and like
that was important to me that it be like
no this is like a fun and like sort of
charming movie
not like a
like a dark nihilistic movie
fun and charming but i was very
surprised by the reason why this movie
kept me up at night i just didn't expect
that deeper exploration of aging and
what it means and really got under my
skin but in the best possible way all
right i'm gonna put up the spoiler
warning now so you can talk about these
next things freely and we will save it
for later so of course i've got my own
thoughts on this but it's different when
it's coming from you
why was it important for you for mia to
play both the roles and did you ever
even for a second consider having her
just play maxine
no i if i didn't think she could have
done it maybe but i always wanted that
character to be played
those characters be played by the same
actor
um one because of the craft of the
special olympics makeup and two because
i think
the
you know
people kind of want to be where they're
not you know it's like when i get there
it's going to be better and then when
you get there you realize oh if i could
just go back it would be better you know
this is a common thing in sort of life
in general and i felt like there's a
duality of those characters and i think
that it like they're different people
but they're kind of the same character
just different places and so that always
felt to me to be an interesting
challenge for an actor challenge for
special effects makeup and then just
thematically and from the cinema craft
thing i keep going on about it just all
seemed to be like sensible way to do it
um well actually not a sensible way
absurd way to do it but like if pulled
off
like a memorable cool thing to do and
that's really that was the drive for
most of it i'm very well done with that
so i was reading in the press notes that
you said that mia was just especially
fearless and never afraid to really put
herself out there while doing this so
can you give us an example of a time
when mia really went above and beyond
with that fearlessness and a particular
scene is better off because of it well
amiga's just like it's she has this very
like once you're rolling she has a very
sort of wild energy that you never quite
know what you're gonna get which i think
works especially well for maxine because
it's someone who like you know all these
characters in the movie have their own
goals and their own like uh what they're
trying to get out of this experience but
none of them are taking as seriously as
maxine is you know and so like
mia i think relates to that has an
element of that of just sort of like i'm
going 110 like and you're gonna have to
like you know if you ever did like a
fight scene with mia you'd be like we
gotta be careful like because like you
know it is what it is and so and then
when she was pearl i mean it's not so
far as to say it was like oh my god we
forgot it was her and it was all what
but it kind of was
because eight hours of makeup every day
does turn you into a different person
not just visually but it's that's a long
time to send the chair she'd get up at
three in the morning every day for six
to eight hours before we even started
the 10 to 12 hour day you know and so
that's a that's a lot and that's it's
heavy and it's just a lot to take on so
it was a little bit like treating
uh
not an old pair but like it's a somewhat
invalid person in a way because we were
always helping around she had context
you can really see so it was just an odd
experience and then
she just embodied those she wasn't so
method that you would never talk to mia
through the makeup but like you just
stopped talking to me through the makeup
because it it was so convincing and
that's also a credit to wedda and their
amazing work to wrap up here one thing
that i've been thinking of quite a bit
what do you think could have made things
better for pearl like even if pearl did
get the life that she dreamed of do you
think that the realities of aging would
have caught up to her anyway
i mean that's a relatively existential
question so it's like it's hard to
necessarily say for sure i think that
i mean i think that in many ways that
question is more interesting than the
answer and i'm not trying to dodge what
you're saying i'm just saying that let's
say she did
become whoever she wants to be let's say
maxine does become whoever she wants to
be will they really be happy i don't
know i guess only time will tell
big part of the reason the movie has not
left my mind since i saw it
again ty congratulations love your stuff
every single movie you give me something
fresh and different your range is insane
and i love it
all right i appreciate it hopefully i'll
deliver next time as well i believe it
thanks a lot guys